when I was starting my entrepreneurial
journey I was reading tons and tons of
self-help books and motivation books and
positive psychology books and it's just
because I was unhappy I'd read 10 books
on like positive psychology and
self-help and my life was still the same
and I didn't like it so if you read a
book and you feel like you're learning
what your life hasn't changed it means
you haven't learned you have to be
willing to try on the other person's
world view and say well do I like the
outcome of their worldview better than
mine if the answer is yes then you
should probably consider shedding your
old world view and finding one that
serves you better I would pay anything
to have obvious truths become real for
me I used to call these singed moments
where it's where something that you've
heard your entire life over and over and
over again but it becomes real for you
it gets internalized the reason Warren
Buffett could lose it all and then
recreate it all in seconds is because of
how he sees reality so anything I can do
to improve my view of reality is
something that I will always invest in